[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILIO DEL TESSANDORO: I'm going
to go through some history, how
storage in Spotify looked
like in the past years.
Then Sandhya is going to
continue with some details
about Cloud Bigtable.
Then I'm going to go through
the migration process
that we are doing at
Spotify, and then I'm
going to add some details about
the Bigtable autoscale app
that we built
during this process.
So some history.
So when I joined Spotify, it
was three years and 1/2 ago.
And we just started
moving to GCP, I remember.
And I'd been exposed marginally
to what was there before.
There was basically
on-prem data centers.
We had four of them--
two in the US and two in Europe.
And so we used to
manage our machines.
And being in the storage
infrastructure team
at the time, and I still am,
we had basically two databases.
So it looked like this.
We had Cassandra and Postgres.
So that means that we also
managed our databases, not just
the machines.
So in this talk, I'm going to
focus quite a lot on Cassandra,
because it became extremely
popular at Spotify,
and I'm going to start telling
you why it became so popular.
In a word, Cassandra
is versatile,
so it can do many
things quite well.
It has tunable consistency.
It has tunable performance.
It has a lot of
knobs that you can
tune to almost optimize at the
use case level, I would say.
It has global application.
It scales pretty well from very
small, like order of megabytes
to terabytes in terms
of data set size.
And it comes with a handy
query language similar to SQL,
and lightweight transactions.
So you can express things
like "INSERT if not exist,"
which is a pretty
powerful feature.
These features made Cassandra
the database for Spotify,
as I said.
And here are some
numbers that I digged--
took me quite a
while to find that,
because from when
Cassandra was at peak,
that was approximately
one year and 1/2 ago.
So yeah, a lot of machines'
load clusters, and in that--
but Cassandra-- yeah.
Even if it was widely
used, it's not perfect.
It comes with a set of problems.
I would say the biggest
is the fact that storage
is coupled to compute, and
this makes topology changes
very expensive.
Because think like, for example,
you are running out of disk,
and you are forced to
scale out your cluster,
even if maybe you don't need
more compute, for example.
And topology changes needs
to shuffle things around,
so it takes a lot
of time, especially
if you have a lot of data.
As I said, it's very
tunable, which is good.
But it's also bad sometimes,
because it's too much.
It has a very long
learning curve.
It means like teams needs to be
experts at operating Cassandra.
And in our case, we managed some
of these clusters-- the most
critical ones.
But in general we believe in
the so-called opposing squads,
so that the teams manage
their own clusters.
So yeah, it comes with a
pretty high operational burden
in that sense.
It scales until it
doesn't, pretty much.
We had some cases
where we really
felt like we
couldn't add any more
nodes to a specific cluster
or it would blow up.
And the Cassandra version we
used, which is not DataStax,
doesn't come with data
exports and backups.
So also that was tricky.
In my team, we used to
build tools, basically,
to alleviate these pains.
So we provide automation to
other teams in the company.
And all sorts of things
that I already mentioned,
like for example, we have
tools for just configuration,
and updating and
topology changes.
One of them is cstar that we
open sourced, that is basically
a parallel SSH, topology aware.
So it knows-- for example, if
you want to restart Cassandra,
it knows in which
order you should
do it to avoid having
unavailable data,
and unavailable ranges of data.
We have cassandra-reaper.
That maybe is the most
famous tool we wrote.
It's about [INAUDIBLE] repairs.
We wrote tools for data
exports, like Hezo.
And Hecuba is for
topology changes--
all sorts of things.
And we eventually got
to a pretty good spot.
Like say, pretty much,
give me a Cassandra cluster
with this number of nodes,
with this machine type,
with backups and exports
on a schedule, and yeah.
So pretty much quite
easy, but there's
a lot of work in
maintaining all these tools,
and some operations are
still extremely expensive.
Like imagine you want
to update the operating
system on 3,000, 4,000 hosts.
It takes a long time.
In this setting, we started
looking at cloud providers,
and we eventually chose GCP.
Not only because of
storage, but the [INAUDIBLE]
was framed in a much
bigger scope, of course.
And the idea was to basically
move up the stack, in a sense.
So free as much as
possible our time,
and do things more closely
related to our business logic,
instead of doing infrastructure
and managing machines.
It should be cheaper, also.
And yeah, that was
basically the idea.
And it should also
be possible to--
so having more time and working
at different abstraction
level to add value on top
of these technologies.
And we have many
success stories of this,
like Scio for
scheduling jobs in--
all sorts of jobs, I guess.
No, sorry.
Styx is for scheduling, and
Scio is for [INAUDIBLE] jobs.
Forseti-- security.
And the autoscaler, I'm
going to talk about later.
I would say we mostly succeeded
in achieving these things,
and now we are fully on GCP.
But even if you're fully
on GCP, the situation
look like this for a while more.
So basically, we just migrated
the physical machines to VMs,
and worked fairly well.
But at some point,
we ask ourselves,
can we use something
that Google is providing?
Like managed storage,
like Cloud Bigtable?
And I will give a--
Sandhya's going to continue
talking about that.
SANDHYA GHAI: Thanks, Emilio.
Yeah, I just want to provide
a brief overview of Cloud
Bigtable and where
we think it delivers
customers value, like Spotify.
So really quickly,
what is Cloud Bigtable?
Cloud Bigtable is
a petabyte-scale,
fully managed NoSQL database.
The original Bigtable technology
was built to index the web,
and in its history, has served
billion-user applications
within Google, like
Gmail and Search.
The Cloud product is meant
to serve use cases where
low latency data access,
scalability, and reliability
are critical.
As a fully-managed service,
it scales seamlessly,
and we're also well-integrated
with the Apache ecosystem,
offering an HBase API.
And Bigtable sits within
a broader portfolio
of database and storage
products, all of which
remove the burden of
building and managing
storage and infrastructure.
Specifically, it sits in
the non-relational space
as a wide column store.
Again, offering super
high performance
in terms of latency
and throughput.
So what can Cloud
Bigtable offer you?
Where does the value come from?
I tend to focus on four areas--
speed, scalability, full
management, and integrations.
I'll talk about speed and
scalability more in a second,
because I think that's what's
differentiating about Bigtable.
And integration with
a broader ecosystem
is what allows it to plug
easily into your existing
architecture.
But I want to pause for a
second on full management,
because this is something
we're thinking about very
holistically.
What does it-- what can we do
to lessen the operational cost
of managing a database?
And so some of that, yes, is
managing the infrastructure
and database layer, having RSREs
paged so that you're not paged.
It also means delivering the
availability, data durability,
and security that you've
come to expect from Google.
But for me, it also
means providing
value add tools to make
the database easier
to work with in every way.
So one quick example of
that is Key Visualizer,
which we launched last year
at Next, which is basically
a heat map of your key space
and shows data access patterns.
So again, not only are we
managing that infrastructure
and keeping you
from getting paged,
we're also giving you
visibility into your data
and making the
parts of the process
that you own, like schema
design, a lot easier.
So again, as a
managed service, we're
thinking a lot about how to
reduce that operational burden.
And as promised, jumping
into speed again.
This is where I think
Bigtable is unique.
On the throughput
side, we're offering
10 megabytes per second
in write throughput,
and 220 megabits per second
in read scan throughput.
I want to emphasize here that
generally in Bigtable, reads
and writes are the same price.
So customers with write-heavy
workloads, in particular,
will see excised
performance because
of that high write throughput.
And we also offer low
latency random data access
in the single-digit
milliseconds.
Scalability-- so
I think there are
two things to focus on here.
Again, Bigtable
was built for scale
and has the ability to handle
internet-sized applications.
That's because performance,
which we measure in
QPS, Queries Per
Second, scales linearly
as you increase the
number of nodes.
I think our published
guidelines say
that you should expect
10,000 QPS per node,
and that's true whether you
have three nodes or 300.
And second, you can scale up and
scale down with Bigtable super
easily.
Again, this is what
makes Bigtable price
effective for spiky workloads,
because you can scale up
to handle the spike and back
down when things cool down.
And Emilio's going to speak
a little bit about how
they leveraged this
characteristic in building
their autoscaler to
get cost savings.
To dive a little bit
deeper on how Bigtable
is able to deliver that
performance and scale,
I want to touch a little
bit on how Bigtable works.
So Bigtable separates
the processing layer
from the storage
layer, which allows
us to optimize throughput
by adjusting the association
of storage and nodes.
So in this example, we
start with three nodes
and four splits of the data
that are stored separately
in our storage layer.
And in the rebalancing
example, we
might be seeing heavy
traffic to data group A.
And so node one is experiencing
a large load in this case.
Bigtable is going
to automatically
rebalance and move some of
that traffic to another load,
ensuring broader, better
overall performance.
And again, resizing
comes into play
when another node
is added to the mix.
And again, we're
able to rebalance
without any downtime, because
instead of moving data around,
we're just reassigning the
node to a different data group.
I also wanted to touch
base on one feature
that's been recently
made available,
and that Spotify has leveraged
pretty intensely, which
is Cloud Bigtable Replication.
Replication allows you to
increase your availability
with a 99.99% SLA by
allowing you to failover
in the case of a geo disaster.
It also allows you to isolate
batch and serving workloads.
And finally, if you're
replicating globally,
like Spotify does, you can
serve a global user base
by offering customers
low latency data
access to local replicas.
There are a few things that
I think are special here.
You write data once,
and you can write data
to any one of those replicas.
And it's automatically
replicated everywhere
with zero consistency.
And finally, there
are no manual steps,
so you're not writing
tools to repair data
or synchronize
writes and deletes.
Replication just works, and
will eventually be consistent.
We have a-- if you're
interested in learning more
about replication,
I hope you'll join
Carter Page, our
engineering manager,
in talking about it tomorrow.
That is DBS 307 at 2:10
PM, Building a Global Data
Presence.
That's my quick plug.
But yeah, handing it
back over to Emilio
to talk about how they
approach the migration.
EMILIO DEL
TESSANDORO: Thank you.
So yeah, our migration--
well, we have first just a short
recap about what Sandhya said.
The Cloud Bigtable is
managed, is eventually
consistent like Cassandra, but
no lightweight transactions.
Storage is decoupled
from compute
and is designed
for big data sets.
So the first thing
you might ask yourself
is, is Cassandra the
same thing as Bigtable?
And yeah, the answer
is, most of the time,
you can map data sets that you
had on Cassandra to Bigtable.
We found at Spotify that
the most common scenarios
that we can map very
well are eventually
consistent or low
consistency needs when
we have ephemeral or
semi-persistent data.
Maybe you have regionally
partitioned data.
And by this, I mean that
a certain set of the data
is accessed only
from certain regions.
Like for example, European
data is only accessed in Europe
and so on, because they
have some cool features that
are available in that way--
the single row
transactions, basically.
And of course, large data sets.
This use case map very well.
Other use cases,
they don't map well.
We found that we had,
as you can imagine,
some cases where we use
this "INSERT if not exist."
And this is not
available in Bigtable.
So you simply have to
find something else.
And also, we have
quite a lot, and this
was unexpected at the beginning,
of this so-called small key
value stores, we call.
So we have not much data--
maybe order of from
megabytes to a few gigabytes.
But still, you need to
have a global replication,
so to have low latency globally.
And then you have very, very
low, or sometimes very high,
QPS.
This also doesn't map well.
So summarizing,
this is the truth
that we found during
our migration.
So there is a pretty big overlap
between Cassandra and Bigtable
for this low consistency and
high throughput scenarios.
And we have these two use
cases that they call "small k-v
stores" and more consistent.
And I am fairly sure
that there is nothing
in the blue part of this graph.
So it's all one of these
three cases, basically.
At least at Spotify.
It took a while
to find out this.
I suggest if you're doing
a migration like this,
try to figure out these
things beforehand.
Just don't say, oh, yeah.
Go and use Bigtable,
and-- because people
is going to come
back to you and say,
well yeah, but we don't
have these features
and now it doesn't work.
And for us, was
also kind of funny,
because at the beginning,
we had two features that
were very important for
us that were missing--
backups, for which we
built an internal stopgap
solution, and
global replication,
that now is available.
But at the time, we
built a custom replicator
based on Cloud Pub/Sub.
And really, it was a potentially
consistent replicator,
because at some point, we
found that basically, you could
lose some data, especially--
if I remember
correctly, was something
about ordering [INAUDIBLE]
inserts and deletes.
Yeah, so it was pretty funny
that after two weeks, oh, yeah.
Oh, wow.
We could lose data.
Yeah.
Anyway, these two features
now are available and yeah,
we use them a lot.
At least-- sorry, the
global replication backups.
Maybe you're going to
get a question about--
[LAUGHS]
And so now immigration
is going slowly.
We are, I would say, halfway.
But yeah, we see that the
number of Bigtable nodes
is increasing, and the number of
Cassandra nodes is decreasing.
As a success story
of migration, I
would like to talk about
the playback cluster.
That basically implements-- is
very crucial for implementing
the Connect feature.
If you're familiar
with that, any store
is basically the device state.
So we have multiple
devices, like TV speakers,
and store the state
of these devices.
The state can be
pretty big, depending
on how the device works.
And it's low consistency data.
If you lose a state or you
just didn't generate a new one,
it's not a super big deal.
And you need a very,
very high performance.
Because imagine you skip
a song, you go off--
that's a change
of the state, so--
and if you count how many users,
how many devices there are,
it's like hundreds of
thousands of requests.
In particular, we used to
have on Cassandra 150,000
QPS at peak.
In three data centers, we
used to have 450 machines
with 7,000 cohorts, more or
less, and 2.5 petabytes of SSD,
just for this cluster.
And this was one of
the examples where
I was saying, like this cluster
was really pushed to the limit.
We couldn't add another
100 nodes to this cluster.
The team managing this cluster,
we used to have, I believe,
one incident a day, during
the last weeks of life.
And as a fun fact, or I
would say what was tragically
bad about this
cluster, is that we
were using just very
little of the disk
for the actual unique
data, because we
had to over-provision a
lot in terms of disk space
to handle Cassandra compactions.
You don't want to run out
of disk space in a Cassandra
cluster, and we had
to provision a lot
to prevent that, basically.
And the data is very ephemeral.
So yeah, a lot of compactions.
On Bigtable, it
worked out very well.
We recently migrated, like
three, four months ago.
The team is very happy.
They didn't have any
operational headaches so far.
We autoscaled this cluster,
in between 150-250 nodes,
so we also have less nodes.
And we pay for the
data that we use,
so we have approximately
40 terabytes of unique data
and just pay for that.
It was also nice, because
we've worked pretty closely
with Google engineers that
were developing a new client--
Java client.
And working with the
Emulator is also cool,
so yeah, it was a
very nice experience.
And this is a chart of
the cost drop the day
we shut down the
Cassandra machines.
You can see in green
the Compute Engine cost.
It doesn't goes down to
zero, because we also
have the service
nodes in the project.
But nevertheless, it's
approximately a 75% drop
in cost, which is pretty big.
Just a few words on how
we did this migration.
It's an online migration,
so we didn't say,
OK, now the feature is disabled
for a few hours and we swapped,
but it was always online.
What we did is we implemented
a storage interface
based on Bigtable, and we run
that together with Cassandra.
And of course, Cassandra
was the primary database
for this process, and we
slowly sent traffic to Bigtable
in order to detect bugs, to
detect problems, or understand
performance.
In general, to gain confidence
that everything works.
And by doing that, you
can also compare the data
that you read from
Cassandra, the data
Bigtable, and see
that everything makes sense.
And so yeah, as I was
saying, the more confidence
you get, the more traffic
you can send to Bigtable,
and eventually 100%
read and write.
And when you feel
good, you do the swap
between Cassandra and Bigtable.
And eventually,
you drop Cassandra.
So it's pretty simple.
It's pretty simple, because
this kind of data is ephemeral.
So eventually, basically
your two database
converge the same data.
And if you have a few errors,
it's fine in this case,
or in cases like this.
And in cases where you
have persistent data,
so you cannot tolerate errors--
like let's say our
playlists cluster.
It's much more tricky, at least
with the Cassandra version
that we have.
In general, it's tricky because
keeping in sync to distributed
databases is not the best.
But there is a pretty
difficult problem
to solve around deletes.
That even if you sync often the
data from the two databases,
like-- the deletes are
not in the data export,
unless you do logical deletes.
If you don't do
logical deletes, you
need to change the schema,
which is also very painful.
Google has a solution
for this, which
is based on newer versions of a
Cassandra, which we don't use.
Yeah, we are
working around this.
Another thing we
are working on is
trying to obstruct, let's
say, the database layer.
So having an interface
that obstructs away
which database we are using.
Like you may interact with
Cloud Spanner or Cloud Bigtable
or Cassandra more or
less in the same way.
And this is something
more for the future,
so maybe if we have
to do this again,
it's going to be
much less painful.
But we could also implement
pretty cool things,
like doing this dual storage
transparently for the user.
It's a pretty cool project
and hopefully we're
going to open source
it if it works.
Said that, during
this process, we also
developed an
autoscaler, which it
wouldn't be impossible
with Cassandra at all.
Because as I said, changing the
number of nodes in a Cassandra
cluster takes time, especially
a big cluster, it take days.
And so with Bigtable,
it's very, very nice
to scale up and
down within minutes.
It started as a
hack project and it
was taken from bits and
pieces of other autoscaler--
I think we had five
autoscalers at some point,
so we have to build
one to rule them all,
and so we call in the
amazing Bigtable autoscaler.
And it's very simple set up.
It's a Java microservice with
some state kept in a Cloud SQL
database.
It basically-- the
logics more less
fetch the cluster
status every 30 seconds,
I believe,
interconnection or not.
And it's open source.
Before going more into the
details of the logic, which
is very simple, I
just want to show
what is the effect of
using the autoscaler.
Normally-- so when you have a
constant amount of resources--
in this case, a constant
amount of nodes,
you would say that you have
day and night cycles in CPU.
In Cassandra, for example,
that was the case,
because you have more
users during the day,
less users during the night.
Using autoscaler,
we see the opposite.
So we can keep the
CPU utilization
pretty much constant and
changing the resources
over time.
And yeah, this graph shows
that it works pretty well.
And it works also for
replicated clusters,
because we do the scaling
at the cluster level,
not at the instance level.
So we can scale independently
different regions, basically.
And the logic, as I was
saying, is very simple.
So basically, the user
defines a target load,
and the autoscaler--
so then given you have
a number of nodes, n,
it just tries to calculate
n1, such that the load
is what the user defined.
It's just an arithmetic
proportion, basically.
And then we have some checks.
We want to respect
some properties,
so it's very simple
state machine.
For example, we want to respect
the storage per node quota.
Otherwise, the cluster
stop receiving writes.
We want to have n1, so
the new number of nodes
should be within the
boundaries that the user sets.
And also, we don't want to
scale too frequently, because--
one is because we have a certain
amount of admin operations,
so there is a quota
on admin operations.
But also, we have
some latency spikes
associated to upscales
or downscales, which
is also something we are
working with Google to solve.
Yeah, but as you see,
it's very simple logic.
And for us, worked really well.
The only real problem we found
is related to data jobs--
Dataflow jobs, in our case--
because they are like sudden
spikes of load on the cluster,
and the autoscaler
cannot scale fast enough.
So basically-- and I think
that the general recommendation
from Google is like, if you
are doing a very heavy Dataflow
job, you should upscale
like 20 minutes before.
And that's the solution.
Another solution could be
throttling the Dataflow jobs.
Indeed, it sounds pretty
crazy, but it's fairly doable
if you use a framework.
And in our case, we
used a framework, Scio.
So we could implement in Scio.
Say start slow and slowly
increase the rate in a way
that the autoscaler
can cope with that.
Another solution could
be to use a predictive--
transforming in a
predictive process,
or integrate some predictions,
like Facebook Prophet.
And this would work if
you have Dataflow jobs
on a certain schedule, not if
you have random during the day.
Right now, we went
with the second one,
because it was the
recommendation,
and it's more or less what
we were already doing.
So yeah-- and it works so far.
So yeah, wrapping
up, managed is great.
We love it.
Our teams are very happy when
moving away from Cassandra.
We think for us it's
the way forward,
because we want to free as
much as our time as possible.
The migration is
not an easy process.
You still need to
understand what's--
you can't completely forget
how things works, of course.
And I would say if there
is one key takeaway for us
in our storage
infrastructure theme,
is that you need to
make the process as
easy as possible for the user.
So like documentation, like
evangelizing good migrations.
The most you can
do-- or tooling also.
The most you can do for
them, the better it is.
And yeah, autoscaling is
a great example of value
that we can evangelize.
I did on top of this.
And yeah, the time and--
mostly the time.
I'm not even sure how
much money we are saving,
but the time savings
are a big win.
[MUSIC PLAYING]